on this Frontier the safest places under
the ground
these trenches are built by Ukraine's
border guards they're the first line of
defense against another Russian invasion
there are now thousands of Russian
troops stationed in Belarus intelligence
reports suggest they might attack soon
yes they to become a more aggressive but
Belarus is just a few kilometers away
viewed through the sights of a heavy
machine gun
Russia can fire shells directly into
this area from its Mainland and it does
every day
it's an unpredictable Place suddenly
they see a Russian military vehicle
nearby we're told to run
up here hidden from sight in the woods
they prepare and practice and that
process is intensifying
Ukraine
I trust in this a british-made anti-tank
weapon but repelling a Russian Convoy
would need a lot of these
we want many weapons we need many
weapons because we are the first line
foreign
if Russia does attack these border
guards will confront them first they do
have a variety of weapons here but they
don't have enough
it's time to leave the base bomber the
dog comes to wave us away well we are
just a few kilometers from the border
there is a Minefield on that side of the
vehicle we just heard incoming Fire
coming from Russia six months ago the
Russian troops abandoned these roads if
they were to come back to invade through
Belarus this is the terrain they would
need to conquer
it's only eight months since the
Russians last poured troops across the
border
the nearest town was occupied and
battered
the scars are still obvious
we found an unexploded rocket lying in
the woods
and there's a trail of charred buildings
the smell of burning still hangs in the
air
but the damage runs deeper Nina shows me
the cellar where she plans to go if the
Russians return this is where you would
hide
foreign
peaceful people who live in a volatile
place now shaped by The Echoes of
Russian aggression and every day they
wonder if it will happen again
Adam Parson Sky News Northern Ukraine